hello I am David Kaplan and I am NOT an
expert but I hope in this series to
learn as much as possible and explain it
to you the best way I can
imagine being in the desert the desert
which is very uniform you look in any
direction you see the same thing that
seeing the same thing means there's a
symmetry in that state it's a rotational
symmetry
now take the desert and add roads and
casinos lots of stuff now every
direction you look looks completely
different that is a situation where an
underlying symmetry exists but the state
of the system breaks it this is
something that occurs with the laws of
nature it is these broken symmetries the
underlying hidden symmetries in the laws
that allow us to discover deeper and
deeper aspects of forces and particles
the Higgs boson is a great example of
that the higgs boson was predicted as
something that breaks a symmetry of the
theory of fundamental particles called
the standard model the symmetry that was
broken has effects like making the
electron and the neutrino completely
different the electron is a particle
that lives in the atom it has electric
charge it's very important for all of
matter and the neutrino moves through
space near the speed of light fills the
universe but otherwise doesn't seem very
important how could these two particles
have been roughly the same particle in
the early universe that's because we
discovered there's a symmetry that
connects them and at some point as the
temperature of the universe cooled that
symmetry broke and the breaking was due
to the Higgs mechanism and the theory
that predicted that breaking also
predicted the particle that was just
discovered a few years ago so the
insights which are what are the
symmetries that guide and structure the
fundamental laws lead to discoveries
like the Higgs and a deeper
understanding about how all particles
and forces work
you